[Music]
in ancient kyoto
a devout shinto scholar lived a simple
life
but he was often distracted from his
prayers by the bustling city
he felt that his neighbors were
polluting his soul
and he sought to perform some kind of
personal
harae a purification ritual that would
cleanse his body
and his mind he decided to travel to the
revered
he shrine the trip was an arduous climb
that took
all day but he was glad for the solitude
it afforded him and the peace he felt
upon returning home
was profound the scholar was determined
to maintain this clarity for as long as
possible
and resolved to make this pilgrimage
another
99 times he would walk the path
alone ignoring any distractions in his
quest for balance
and never straying from his purpose the
man was true to his word
and as days stretched into weeks he
walked through driving rain and searing
sun
over time his devotion revealed the
invisible world of spirits
which exists alongside our own
he began to sense the kami which
animated the rocks underfoot
the breeze that cooled him and the
animals grazing in the fields
still he spoke to no one spirit or human
he was determined to avoid contact with
those who had strayed from the path
and become polluted with kegare this
taboo of defilement
hung over the sick and deceased as well
as those who defiled the land
or committed violent crimes of all the
threats to the scholar's quest for
spiritual purity
kigare was by far the greatest
after paying his respects for the 80th
time
he set out for home once more but as
darkness fell
he heard strained sobs in the night air
the scholar tried to push forward and
ignore the moans
but the desperate cries overwhelmed him
grimacing he left his path to follow the
sound
to its source he soon came to a cramped
cottage with a woman crumpled outside
filled with pity the scholar implored
the woman to share
her sorrow she explained that her mother
had just died
but no one would help her with the
burial
at that news his heart sank
touching the body would defile his
spirit draining his life force and
leaving him forsaken
by the kami but as he listened to her
cries
his sympathy soared and so
they buried the old woman together to
ensure her safe passage
into the spirit world the burial was
complete
but the taboo of death weighed heavily
on the scholar
how could he have been so foolish to
shirk his most
important rule and corrupt his divine
journey
after a tormented night he resolved to
go back to the shrine
to cleanse himself to his surprise
the usually quiet temple was filled with
people
all gathering around a medium who
communicated directly with the kami
the man hid himself not daring approach
in case
anyone glimpsed his polluted soul but
the medium had other ways of seeing and
called him forward from the crowd
ready to be forsaken the scholar
approached the holy woman
but the medium merely smiled
she took his impure hand in hers and
whispered a blessing
only he could hear thanking him
for his kindness in that moment the
scholar discovered a great
spiritual secret contamination and
corruption are two very different things
filled with insight the scholar set
himself back on his journey
but this time he stopped to help those
he met
he began to see the beauty of the spirit
world everywhere he went
even in the city he'd previously shunned
others cautioned that he risked kegare
but he never told them
why he so freely mingled with the sick
and disadvantaged for he knew
that people could only truly understand
harai
through a journey of their own
dive deeper into traditional japanese
culture with this video on the ancient
dramatic art of kabuki
or find out how fishermen bragged about
their giant catches before the invention
of photography
with this video on jayutaku
[Music]
you